so you're allergic to nuts like what
happens to you if you eat nuts I have
like yeah I go into an anaphylactic
shock so you guys have you ever
accidentally been served nuts that just
happened on this movie I did I was doing
a scene with Luke Wilson uh in the
skeleton Twins and they were bringing
around little chocolate things and I'm
like oh yeah I'll have a little boy and
I ate it and it was full of peanut
butter and what happened I went to
Affleck I was rushed to the emergency
room wow you really go full blown yeah
and then the doctor the guy in the
emergency room it was so great it was in
Westchester but he was such a like you
and he goes you carry an EpiPen with you
and I go no and he goes you're an idiot
because I'm telling you right now you're
an idiot he's like you got to carry an
every penny because the fact that you're
even eating anything that might have
nuts in it you're a [__] what is he I
don't know about this what is the EpiPen
do it gives you a shot of adrenaline and
it helps you it get over again it opens
you up against you because the the shock
can cause you you to stop breathing yeah
yeah and it's like you're breathing
through a garden hose and when you're in
but when you're in the uh when you're
there and you suddenly take a bite into
some peanut butter even if you don't
swallow it if it just gets into your
system this can happen and do you turn
to everyone go quick get me to the
hospital no I was like I can I'll be
honest because I started doing
I started doing TM yeah because I was
listening to your show and I started
doing TM and I go I can control
I go I can control this and then Luke
Wilson's looking at me like what the
[__] wrong with you and I'm like and I
go I can't breathe I gotta get out of
here are you still doing TM yeah yeah
this morning yeah it is yeah yeah and
that's helped with the anxiety and stuff
yeah I did before the iOS take an EpiPen
with you anyway yeah yeah that's what I
I saw Owen Wilson at the show and I said
tell your brother I'm all right and he's
like yeah because you can't be a tough
guy with a with a with a peanut outage
first time that happened to you Bill
lose it uh did you we were you a little
kid I was a little I was two years old
and my parents were like on a camping
trip oh my God middle of nowhere and I
started free and I started swelling up
and they were like oh so they knew what
it was but yeah I just had to get
through it yeah and I got through it and
and when you get when as you get older
it gets it gets actually worse because
Yeah the more exposure you have the
worse it is yeah I also think that the
older you get the more you're afraid of
dying and then and and into fear it also
just might be just the anxiety of it
it's like I ate a thing and then I'm
like so I don't know like I asked the
doctor I go how much of this is that I'm
feeling as an anxiety attack and how
much of the peanuts and stuff like that
he goes well if you can't breathe it's a
peanut cheese
[Laughter]